Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since Supernatural
was just confirmed for season 10 I thought
it would be fun to talk about some of the
people and things we’d like to see.
Don’t forget next week will be more olympics
so I’ll probably just do another bonus supernatural
video.
If you’re finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get it.
Before we get to season 10 let’s see where
we’re going to be at the end of this season.
Everybody grab some pie.
This is going to be fun.
First, there’s the war for heaven AND hell.
Let’s start up top.
The real problem is re-opening heaven.
They still haven’t explained what metatron
did that’s keeping them locked out.
So we don’t even fully understand what the
problem is.
That’s basically castiel’s arc this season.
Solving that problem and ostensibly becoming
a wiser more sexed-up god.
With a few extra city miles on him.
I don’t know that i’d forgive the show
if they didn’t make him whole again eventually.
So my first prediction for season 10 is that
Castiel will be made whole, he’ll get his
grace back.
Since the spell that closed heaven has something
to do with his grace, restoring castiel would
have to somehow restore heaven.
Jumping into the fire, Abaddon and Crowley.
Those two need to just get a room already.
It’s really just a question of which one
of them will rule hell.
It’s like now that the angels are on earth,
the demons don’t even care.
They just want their sweet sweet human soul
honey.
Shout out to cain.
The twist I think is coming this season is
that crowley will also be restored, because
who is he if not the other side of that castiel
coin.
My season 10 prediction for crowley is that
he’ll be the king of hell and working with
Sam, Dean and Castiel to defeat Abaddon.
Wait a minute hold the pie, isn’t dean supposed
to kill abaddon with the mark and the first
blade?
Short answer yes, but this season something
is going to stop him from being able to do
it.
Because they could never get rid of Alaina
Huffman.
She is far too precious.
Here’s where my season 10 predictions get
tied up together with Sam, Dean and Abaddon.
So I kind of have to talk about all of them
at the same time.
If you haven’t seen it, I predicted that
because Sam’s possession tattoo was burned
off, Abaddon will end up possessing him preventing
dean from killing samaddon.
Remember that’s why Cain wasn’t able to
kill abaddon.
So my season 10 prediction is that we’ll
start off with Sam still possessed at the
beginning of the season.
The alternative is that Dean is finally able
to get over himself and let Sam die.
And if Supernatural has taught us anything,
it’s that Dean will always be Dean.
He’s not going to change.
At least not permanently.
My Season 10 prediction for Dean is that he’ll
still be carrying around the mark of cain
trying to restore his brother.
At this point there aren’t a lot of places
the story could go without creating a reason
to bring God back into the equation.
And the whole idea of the show is that God
left.
So my other big season 10 prediction is that
we still won’t see god.
There’s no reason to think the show won’t
get a season 11, but if they did want to end
the show completely.
there’s really only a couple ways for them
to do it without getting too silly.
Here they are from least likely to most likely.
Number 5 - They both die and go to heaven.
Finally at peace.
Possible, but highly improbable.
Number 4 - Dean sacrifices himself and Sam
is left to live out the rest of his life as
a hunter.
Remember, there’s always going to be evil
in the world.
So there will always need to be hunters.
This is a slightly more likely outcome.
Number 3 - Their dad returns in a deus ex
machina and sacrifices himself again to try
and make amends for being a terrible dad and
giving them such shitty lives.
Also unlikely, but a final cameo from dad
would be a nice bookend to the series.
And they’d both be alive at the end in this
scenario.
Number 2 - Dean finally grows up inside and
let’s Sam die for real, then tries to live
out the rest of his life trying to figure
out how to stop being a hunter and settle
down.
Slightly more likely, but still not the best
option.
and finally, my number one potential ending
to the series.- Neither of them dies and things
end with them giving the business to another
demon.
This is the ending that would give fans the
story a place to continue like nothing had
happened even if the tv show ends.
So they just keep going on adventures in the
comics and the books, getting themselves into
all kinds of trouble with the help of castiel
and crowley.
Let me know what you’re biggest prediction
for supernatural season 10 is and how you
think they’ll end the series.
Next week I’ll be doing my top 5 characters
to bring back in season 10.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
And new Game of Thrones trailer coming sunday.
I’ll be doing a full breakdown.
So get excited.
Right now click here to learn all about arrow
season 3 and click here for last week’s
episode of supernatural.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!